let's have a go at the expression sir
can someone give me a first line of
working number one I want to suggest
okay what you guys think
sad look alright yeah I keep these to
notice that we get to with the expansion
you're gonna do both turns in there and
then of course in the second one you've
got the minus sign there which we know
is an easy place to make mistakes okay
that's the expand part let's just
simplify bit what we're gonna do here
like terms this is probably easy enough
they never even need to do this but you
guys know I like to get in a habit of
identifying like just before I even
start putting pen to paper like what are
the like terms so that I don't miss any
and I'm going to combine the collect
ones so there's gonna be a - egg is
you've got three take away fall so I'll
actually put that second what about the
number 13 so that was not too complex
hey what do you think what do you reckon
same different it is the same now the
reason it's the same it's a bit sneaky
right when you're adding numbers
together and you're adding numbers
together you can add them in any order
you like yeah 1 + 2 + 2 + 1 Savion
there's a minus sign there which kind of
confuses people but it's moved across
right so this is actually 13 plus
negative a and so you can move the
negative a out the front and it's happy
times good number two without getting to
the lines of working yet if someone want
answer x equals somebody hasn't said
anything yet 6 over 19 I'm happy with
that that matches what I got yeah 6 over
19 what was your I'm looking up right
down but what did you do like the first
line what did you do with this yeah Oh
smells funny he's definitely in the
smart way to go to begin with you can't
really do look at these denominator this
is the cancelling we'll see the plain
you can do without that you're just
gonna multiply across okay excellent
number three number three what are we
gonna do with this to actually work out
the grading like before we get to the
Dunbar what to do is we want two points
right now they're very nicely even if
you've at a point to you because the
graph itself is a little bit awkward you
can see it's not matching up necessarily
O'Mahony points that looks okay right
but the fact that they're giving you
that you kind of - well user right so
you might remember bring in what is
gradient good okay so rise everyone I'm
going to compare the Y values of a pair
of points and then I'm going to compare
the X values for a pair of points right
and you can see here the easy one of
course the tech is that guy what's its
name it has a special name
it's the y-intercept it's on the y axis
you can draw your triangle in here sorry
mister there we go okay and I'm gonna
now compare this which is dropping down
yes it's actually getting negative and
this amount here so y2 minus y1 which
one you want to make the first or second
point which one would you like it
doesn't matter just like we knows before
you can do them in the same water I'm
actually gonna put two and a half first
and six second the reason why this is a
bit unusual because usually we don't
like putting smaller on this first but I
actually want the small number first
this time why do you think that's the
case have a look at it yeah I'm
expecting a negative at the end right so
I might as well get the negative at the
top because it's gonna get there
anywhere right what am i excited I'm
comparing what take away what I've dealt
with I've dealt with the six in the two
and a half this number and this number
the x-coordinates other one and the zero
very good one takeaway zero which in
fact is really really easy cuz now the
denominators one two and a half take
away six of course is minus three
and there's your we say missus lately
it's a caliper give you straight back
again um does that match what the graph
looks like you talking about what you
taking its dropping and it's dropping
like a rock
yeah you didn't use that that's right so
you're gonna have if you're thinking
about that drop right it's gonna be this
value and this value so you've gotta go
all the way down so instead of two and a
half in a big negative one
yeah so that's how far you go and that's
okay you're gonna get I expect yeah
imagine it like with lettuce you can
pick any point on the line and you still
get the same training this doesn't
change your to connect scale you mean if
I went like two four six eight is having
me
okay yeah sure I see what you mean
okay so let me see if maybe if I repeat
back to you what what I understand so if
for example I had something like this is
that the picture you look yeah yeah
and then I've got like a point here and
another point over here let's call that
one too and then how do I work this out
this actually worth we can't because um
these leading relationships we know they
don't go away right we're gonna do look
at these again and again and again so if
I saw this and I had a wine went all the
way through how would I work out this
gradient okay now I'm going to go
through it much the same way I still
what rise I still won't run okay you
just need to be careful in the scale so
when I draw across here this might rain
with it right that you can see this
one's here is three blocks but each one
is half the unit so this is one and a
half but it's going down so in fact it's
negative yeah
what's the month so when I do rise over
right here
hav when I do my rise over run here is
my rise that is my one there and this
looks like it's gonna be well this is
exactly half of this right this is - aha
now here's what becomes a bit of an
issue you look at that you think doesn't
look like - a half and it doesn't look
like - aha that should be really shallow
shouldn't it right and that's because
the scales are different right in fact
this scales is stretched out vertically
so that's why it looks like it's
dropping faster than it actually is but
we know scales are different all the
time like when we get money versus time
scales are completely unrelated so
therefore now let's find the pressure
systems
when you think about what a grading of
come back to one that's what that's the
most important gradient to understand
right if you've got a gradient of rise
over run and it's one that means every
time you go up one you're gonna go
across one so that one it what keeps you
warm now if I come back to here I've got
a great case I'm just gonna use it that
means I go across one up one like that
and you're gonna cross one off one and I
can keep going
so we think about this line that's a 45
degree angle right there
right so great in every one if you think
about that is your most important one
our half will be less stay from that and
like two would be more statement so I'm
just trying to get like a rough idea and
that's how I looked at this and I said
whoa it's super steep so - three and a
half kind of matches what I was
expecting that make sense yeah